good morning and thank whoever made that
warm introduction it's really great to
be here with all of you at Stanford
today I appreciate President Obama's
invitation to discuss these important
topics I also want to acknowledge
secretary Pritzker secretary Johnson
Lisa Monaco and Jeff sites I'm grateful
for the opportunity to join them and
discussing privacy and security at Apple
we designed products that change
people's lives we believe in the power
of values to shape history and we strive
to live those values every single day
we believe the country that made our
success possible should be the land of
opportunity for every American that's
why we support President Obama's connect
ed initiative to equip underserved
schools with cutting-edge technologies
it's why we're committed to hiring
American suppliers and it's why we're
manufacturing more of our products and
components in the United States in fact
our products and innovations so far have
led to the creation of more than 1
million American jobs in all 50 states
we believe in leaving the world better
than we found it and that's why we're on
track to meet our goal of running our
entire company on renewable energy thank
you
we believe in human rights and human
dignity which is why we put so much
thought into how our products are
manufactured not only how they're
designed and we believe deeply that
everyone has a right to privacy and
security and that's why I stand before
you today at Apple we start with this
very simple premise our customers trust
means everything to us and we spent
decades working to earn that trust
that's what privacy and security are
built into every one of our products and
services from their inception we have
strict policies that govern how all data
is handled our networks and systems are
segmented our hardware and software use
encryption and we have a security
operations team monitoring our
infrastructure 24/7 beyond that we have
a straightforward business model that's
based on selling the best products and
services in the world not on selling
your personal data
we don't sell advertisers any
information from your email content from
your messages or your web browsing
history we don't try to monetize the
information you store on your iPhone or
in iCloud when we ask you for data it's
to provide you with better services and
even then you have a choice you're in
the driver's seat on how much
information you share and when you want
to stop sharing it we set the industry's
highest standards and we are deeply
committed to living up to them today so
much of our information is digital our
memories of family and friends and our
photos and our videos our medical
history and our financial transactions
our most private conversations at home
and at work
this comes with great benefits it makes
our lives better easier healthier but at
Apple we have always known this also
comes with a great responsibility we
know hackers are doing everything they
can do to steal your data it's why we've
used all the technology at our disposal
to create the most secure devices and
the most secure systems that we can in
2013 more than 13 million Americans were
victims of identity theft which is now
one of America's fastest growing crimes
in the last few years
hackers have infiltrated some of our
biggest banks and companies stealing the
credit card and debit card information
of hundreds of millions more and just
the other week we saw hackers steal
information from one of America's
largest health care
providers the personal impact of these
security breaches can be devastating by
clicking on the wrong link or simply
using your credit card too many people
have had their identity stolen their
finances threatened and their lives
turned upside-down these offenses cost
our economy billions of dollars every
year there is some good news the good
news is that we have the ability to
protect people from this growing threat
with Apple pay we put in place a mobile
payment system that is significantly
more secure than the old days of the
plastic card and the magnetic stripe
this is another product where security
wasn't an afterthought security was part
of the reason we developed the
technology in the first place
you see Apple pay starts with the
premise that your credit card
information and purchases are personal
to you and they should stay that way
when you add a card to Apple pay your
actual credit card numbers are never
stored in your device or on our servers
instead for every payment we create a
unique one-time code that is only good
for that one transaction from your
device your purchases are private and we
don't store the details of those
transactions they remain between you the
merchant and your bank
we don't know your credit card number or
what you bought or how much you paid and
we don't want to
just three months after we launched over
2,000 banks have signed on to bring
Apple pay to millions of their customers
and today we're excited to announce that
beginning in September Apple pay will be
available for many transactions with the
federal government like for example when
you pay for admission to your favorite
national park we're also working to make
sure credit and procurement cards issued
to government employees for their
expenses can be used with Apple pay and
we're working on initiatives with
leading banks and networks to use this
technology with benefit programs like
Social Security and veterans pensions
that serve citizens at both the state
and federal level we can imagine a day
in the not so distant future when your
wallet becomes a remnant of the past
your passport your driver's license and
other important documents can be
digitally stored in a way that's safe
secure and easy to access but only by
you after all
we shouldn't have to trade our security
for the convenience of having all of
this information at our fingertips when
a system is designed properly security
and convenience can actually work in
harmony this is a world of greater
privacy and a world where criminals find
it much more difficult to carry out
their crimes without a doubt
safeguarding a world of digitized
personal information is an enormous task
and no single company or organization
can accomplish it on its own that is why
we're committed to engaging productively
with the White House and the Congress
and putting the results of these
Congress
Nations into action because when it
comes to the rights of customers and the
rights of citizens it's important to
realize we're all talking about the same
people people have entrusted us with
their most personal and precious
information we owe them nothing less
than the best protections that we can
possibly provide by harnessing the
technology at our disposal and working
together as businesses governments and
citizens we believe we can bring about a
future that fully embraces both privacy
and security we must get this right
history has shown us that sacrificing
our right to privacy can have dire
consequences we still live in a world
where all people are not treated equally
too many people do not feel free to
practice their religion or express their
opinion or love who they choose a world
in which that information can make the
difference between life and death if
those of us in positions of
responsibility fail to do everything in
our power to protect the right of
privacy we risk something far more
valuable than money
we risked our way of life fortunately
technology gives us the tools to avoid
these risks and it is my sincere hope
that by using them and by working
together we will thank you very much
thank you